so first of all how did the opportunity
come to you to be Celebrity Big Brother
it just it just popped on pretty much my
team's doorstep yeah yeah and they asked
me about it and I was intrigued I was
like yes like this is pretty awesome
yeah and my team's like I don't know
you're gonna be on camera 24/7 like I
just don't know if you have the right
time you're training for 2020 Olympics
so I don't know if this will fit and I
was like no I gotta do this you gotta do
this just does it
combat what you're trying to do at the
Olympics though because you're sort of
this weird you know athlete that is like
an athlete a medal podium athlete but
then also sort of a celebrity and these
kind of things are hard you know like
how do you deal with being both of those
things to people um well you know I
guess though I mean what made me a
celebrity was my swimming shows you know
so I mean we'll definitely always comes
first and you know the hardest thing is
me not getting my normal regiment when
I'm on this show yeah so that's gonna be
the hardest thing but there's a there's
we're ways around it yeah you're gonna
be doing push-ups like in the morning it
would be like yeah push-ups in my room
are you nervous about being done Dancing
with the Stars so we know that you've
you can hang with other celebrities
Hollywood types but are you nervous
about being confined in a house with
them no not at all just because I get it
like my personality I get along with
everyone yeah and I don't hold grudges
and I'm not like mean to anyone and I'm
just so I'm nice I'm talkative like I
can talk to anyone and I just I'm like I
guess the cool factor yeah you're cool
most were your friend yeah I feel like I
want to go to your party
yeah now your dad and stuff but like I
still feel like you throw a great party
how tough will it be for you to be out
of contact with your family you got a
new wife's got a new baby baby on the
way
and then also no cell phone yeah what
are we gonna do without Instagram I feel
naked yeah I can't pick up my phone Mike
what's up guys how you guys doing yeah
can't do that I can't
like when I'm gone on like some trips or
whatever
I'm always faced having my family yeah
non-stop so I can see my boy I can I can
sing to the new one in the inner belly
and I can talk to my wife and everything
and I can't do that but I wasn't gonna
do this show without their blessing oh I
know my wife is pregnant she's about 20
weeks and she was like Ryan like no
matter what we got your back like we're
a family we stick together just go out
there and have fun yeah and we're gonna
be okay
so I got her blessing and I'm like if
anything bad happens god forbid oh
they'll let us pull you out and don't
pull me out yeah that won't happen no
well how competitive are you I mean how
can I put it I'm uh I'm an Olympic
athlete I mean I've won a gold medal at
the Olympics so you can say I'm very
competitive
[Laughter]
so I definitely know what it takes to
win and I know different on well in my
swimming career I've had different
things thrown at me different um well it
bumps in the road but I've always had
focused on a goal and I've always met
that goal so you're very very
competitive now are you worried about
being too competitive because if you win
too many of the physical challenges
they're gonna get rid of you yeah you
got like a you're a target yeah so I
known that I think my goal is to win the
first one so I'm the HOH so then I can't
get kicked off yeah but then maybe lose
a couple ya know some yeah if I'm in
that position yeah just so I'm not the
target and you know be nice to everyone
which I am you're pretty nice guy yet
and I get along with everyone so making
those alliances I don't think will be
really hard yeah a lot of people go on a
show like this and they're hoping Oh at
the end everyone falls in love with me
and then I can get this many more
Hollywood jobs but you already know
you're doing on the end of Big Brother
you're going back into training for the
2020 Olympics exactly so you're very
focused yes I'm very focused but you
know if I'm always up for like taking on
new challenges so if something does come
up yeah about like there's a there's
always a way to swim okay
there's always swimming pools somewhere
so I mean it's just like this I have to
find different ways to still train to
where I want to meet my end goals I love
that did you reach out to anyone from
Season one of Celebrity Big Brother to
get advice no you have no advice I
watched the first two episodes two or
three episodes when Chuck Liddell got
kicked off and I was like no yes no
don't let that happen to you Ryan I'm
not I'm not going to okay good the food
situation is very tough inside the house
you're gonna have to eat some slop you
have to be cooking for yourself are you
gonna eat as many eggs as you need to
eat like a hundred thousand eggs a day
right this is all right so this is where
my strategy comes into play - my wife
cooks yeah she does all the cooking so I
don't know how to cook anything not one
thing so I'm gonna like find someone
that loves to cook and I'd be like their
sous chef I'll be like hey you need help
I'll help you be there helpful hand you
get talking really like joking around
form that bond they cook for me I eat
well and we have an alliance already I'm
winning it seems like more of a win-win
for you yes yeah very smart so what is
your strategy for winning well that was
one of my sin just eat some spirit okay
and you know I guess just be myself
because I really feel like because you
have to form these alliances huh and in
order to do that you have to click with
people yeah and I honestly I don't think
there's one person where I've met and
they're like I don't like you like yeah
I've clicked with everyone just because
I'm a nice protocol guy and I don't hold
anything negative and I'm
positive yeah so that positive is like
contagious and everyone wants to be like
around that yeah and so I feel like that
will be one of my advantages okay what
are you gonna do with money the money
250 big smackeroos you know I actually I
put I I always I was always told when
you get a paycheck cut it in half and
put that away okay oh I'm and now that I
have a family I definitely take that
half of the money divide it again in
half and put it towards my college funds
the my kids phones for college and then
the rest would be like just buying like
nurse like we got to build a nursery
like fun stuff oh I'd do that and then
the rest invest it do you think it'll be
easier or harder than Dancing with the
Stars
Big Brother it has to be easier because
I swear I say I will train for hours
every day for four years for swimming
than to do one week of Dancing with the
Stars again it was the heart I was a
fish out of the water
yeah and it was the hardest thing I've
ever had to do this is gonna be easy so
this is gonna be a bruise ah it's gonna
be race so I didn't want to mention this
when we sat down but I can see that you
have a few more gray hairs than last
time I saw you brother Mina daddy is not
easy I know I have been but I love it
yeah I love the gray hair yeah I mean
it's like it's annoying guys get cuter
who do you know you're basically Clooney
at this point why not but yeah you know
since everything that's happened like
gray hairs just pop non-stop it's I mean
but that's life that's nice fun so you
made the announcement you were expecting
a baby girl yes
you don't understand how excited I am
said that like I'm having another child
and it's a girl like it's daddy's little
girl like you know growing up you've
always heard that
that's her being like daddy's little
girl and now I'm gonna have that that's
freaking awesome it's pretty cute yeah
do you have any expectations about
having like one is fun two is too many
no I'm good I have a feeling the girl's
gonna be a lot calmer
yeah then Caden yeah boy he's yeah off
the wall yeah well he's you yeah he's me
you're welcome Oh yep
it sounds like I'm sorry I'm sorry
he's off the walls bouncing and she's
been just like in Kayla my wife's
stomach like she's just been so calm
like Katie was like get me out of here
she's so calm and I'm like ooh this is
gonna be good like you're gonna even
each other up
do you've a name yes do you know what
anyone times I don't want to say your
secret yeah but we had this name picked
out before our son okay this isn't a
family name does have a meaning or is it
just a name you love no it's a name like
I'm obsessed with Oh like herbs like I
hear this name I'm just like oh my gosh
like that's it and so when you heard
you're having a girl were you like I can
use the name yes well we both were me
and my wife were both like guns yeah at
the doctor's office we were jumping
around and we're like yes this is fine
like what we wanted like we wanted a boy
first yeah and then we wanted a girl and
it's happening exactly the way we wanted
do you think this is it one two done I
mean I love children so I don't think
family I'm like you want to go for
number three oh you do
what does Kaden think does he understand
he doesn't really understand the fact
that we're having another baby but like
if we're at like friend's house that
have like little babies and we're
picking them up yeah Caiden's like oh no
that's my daddy that's my mommy no like
very like get off like oh it's gonna be
it's gonna be kind of interesting I
think the first like week or so he's
gonna be like what the heck what about
me yeah but I mean we have we have such
big
hearts that we shared the love with
everyone but when I came home from the
hospital my brother said send her back
Sen service send her back send her back
okay so when you get out of the Big
Brother house between now and 2020 like
what's what's there I'm going back into
training I'm missing so they're starting
really hard training right now and I
missed that I'm gonna be missing that
and I won't get back into training into
my first competition back is in July
are you still crushing like we only
really get to see you when it's the
Olympics like are you still crushing
like you're gonna be in the Olympics
right I haven't I haven't really swim
since last Olympics what cuz I've been
suspended from everything that's
happened yeah and then so I just spent
this on suspension and I've just been
training a little bit and training a
little bit on my own yeah and that's it
but my first competition back is in July
and then hopefully so if you crush that
then you'll have a good idea time for
lyrics well I'm definitely trying for
the Olympics no matter what but it will
be a good indicator for the rest of the
world that I'm coming okay well this
you're gonna win big brother and then
you're gonna win another girl
[Music]